[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
wir beginnen diese Sendung mit dem Blick
nach Brasilien von dort erreichten uns
vor einer guten Stunde diese Bilder
Anhänger des rechtsgerichteten
ehemaligen Präsidenten bolsonaro
stürmten den Kongress in der Hauptstadt
Brasilia zerschlugen Scheiben zerstörten
Möbel Szenen die an den Sturm auf das
amerikanische Parlament vor zwei Jahren
erinnern weil zur Nachos Nachfolger Lula
das Silva war erst vor einer Woche
vereidigt worden der ehemalige Präsident
hatte seine Wahlniederlage nie
eingeräumt
fragen wir unseren Brasilien
Korrespondenten Christoph völkerath in
Rio Christoph wie überraschend kommt
diese Aktion der bolsonaro Anhänger und
was bedeutet sie
sie kommt tatsächlich relativ
überraschend und das ist die eigentliche
news today zu heute weil es nämlich so
war das offenbar mehr als 4.000 wolltest
du naro Anhänger in den letzten Tagen
mit Bussen aus dem ganzen Land in
Brasilia angereist sind das ganze muss
also irgendwie koordiniert gewesen sein
und die Frage ist warum haben die
Behörden nicht entsprechend reagiert der
zuständige Polizei Chef des
bundesstriktes in Brasilia ist bereits
entlassen worden wegen handelt es sich
um einen bekennenden bolzenario-anhänger
Frage also ob es da einen Zusammenhang
gibt es gibt auch verstörende Bilder von
Polizisten die teilweise mit solchen mit
den randalieren posiert haben für Fotos
und die noch Getränke und sowas gebracht
haben also das ist die große Frage im
Moment ist es immer noch so dass zwei
der Präsidentenpalast und der Oberste
Gerichtshof von den Sicherheitsbehörden
geworden wurden von den randalieren aber
immer noch welche sich im Parlament
befinden und das ist eben die
eigentliche Frage wie es überhaupt
passieren konnte und was das heißt bei
Brasilien Land fast seit fast 40 Jahren
die Militär hinter sich gelassen hat
eine sehr gute Verfassung hat auch sehr
stolz darauf die Gewaltenteilung und wie
konnte diese stolze Demokratie sich
jetzt so kalt erwischen lassen sagt ich
meine natürlich sagen manche geht hier
die Saat von Präsident bolsonaro auf der
in seinen vier Jahren der Amtszeit immer
wieder mit Fake News über Social Media
und so weiter die Axt an die Demokratie
hier angelegt hat so dass eben viele
seiner Anhänger anscheinend nicht mehr
bereit sind auf einem demokratischen
Boden zu bleiben und dieses knappe
Wahlergebnis für du da zu akzeptieren
vielleicht zum Abschluss noch eines ist
daran keine Sitzungen heute im Parlament
herr Präsident ist auch nicht da wird
sich nach äußern auch die obersten
Richter waren nicht da deswegen könnte
es abgesehen von den großen Sachschäden
und für die Demokratie einigermaßen
glimpflicht ausgehen wenn die Behörden
jetzt die Oberhand gewinnen
vielen Dank für diese ersten
Einschätzung herzlichen Dank nach Rio
seit vier Monaten wehren sich Frauen und
Männer gegen die Unterdrückung durch das
molaregime im Iran das zu immer härteren
Maßnahmen greift am Wochenende wurden
zwei weitere Demonstranten nach
Schauprozessen hingerichtet zornig sind
die Menschen im Iran auch weil sich
heute zum dritten Mal ein Zwischenfall
jährt der für sie die Kaltblütigkeit des
Regimes
das Regimes symbolisiert im Januar 2020
schießen die revolutionsgarten einen
ukrainisches Zivilflugzeug ab und
versuchen den Vorfall zunächst zu
vertuschen Jörg Brase berichtet aus
Teheran
Angehörige der Opfer trauern und
protestieren vor drei Jahren starben an
diesem Ort am Stadtrand Teherans 176
Menschen Irans Militärs hatten
versehentlich eine ukrainische
Verkehrsmaschine abgeschossen erst nach
Tagen hatte Irans Regierung den Fehler
zugegeben bis heute streiten Angehörige
für eine genaue unter Untersuchung und
Bestrafung der Schuldigen
ich empfinde großen Schmerz gleich
kommen mir die Tränen denn auch von mir
saßen Verwandte in diesem Flugzeug nicht
nur diese 176 waren die Opfer sondern
tausende von uns sind betroffen
der Abschuss sei ein weiteres Verbrechen
des Regimes sagen Oppositionsgruppen und
riefen zum Jahrestag der Katastrophe zu
Straßenprotesten auf dem folgten einige
tausend wie in Isfahan oder Sananda doch
das harte Vorgehen der Behörden zeigt
Wirkung viele trauen sich nicht mehr auf
die Straße die ehemalige
reformabgeordnete havanes salaschury
kennt das von vorangegangenen Unruhen
aus Protest gegen die staatliche
Repressionspolitik trat sie bei der
letzten Wahl nicht mehr an
das System denkt dass das harte
durchgreifen gut war dass die Politik
der eisernen Faust geholfen hat dass die
Proteste kleiner werden und wenn Sie
denken dass sie effektiv waren werden
sie auch genauso weitermachen dass mir
mit
dazu passt die neueste
Personalentscheidung von
revolutions-radan zum neuen Polizei-Chef
radanlies bereits frühere Proteste
blutig niederschlagen
neben Angst vor harten Strafen mag wohl
auch die rekordinflation Grund sein für
ein abschwächen der Protestwelle hohe
Preise bei gleichbleibend niedrigen
Löhnen es ist der Kampf ums tägliche
Brot der tatsächlich nur den Bäcker
zufrieden macht
die Leute kaufen mehr Brot weil Reis und
Nudeln einfach zu teuer geworden sind
Brot ist das günstigste was ich die
Leute leisten können
und es ist wohl auch die Angst vor noch
größeren Chaos die viele zögern lässt
sich den Protesten anzuschließen die
Proteste haben überall Auswirkungen
gehabt auch auf die Arbeit im Büro sind
Behörden klar die Situation gefällt
keinem keiner will dass es so weitergeht
aber ich hoffe trotzdem dass es
irgendwann besser wird
zunächst aber wird es erstmal wieder
ruhiger und ist wohl doch nur die Ruhe
vor dem nächsten Stock
darüber wollen wir reden mit Omid
nuripur dem ko-vorsitzenden der Grünen
der mit 13 Jahren aus dem Iran nach
Deutschland flog guten Abend nach Berlin
schönen guten Abend
was ist ihre Sichtweise auf das was
gerade in Iran passiert schlägt das
Regime die Protestbewegung gerade nieder
es gibt eine große Reihe von weiteren
Protesten Protestformen jeden Abend
skandieren die Leute von ihren Balkon
von den Dächern der Protest rufe raus es
werden Banner von Revolutionsführer in
die Runde gerissen das ist überhaupt
nicht zu Ende aber die Erfahrung die
Leute machen ist die gehen auf die
Straße und protestieren wegen Verschluss
Verschmutzung wegen einer furchtbaren
wirtschaftlichen Lage wegen vielen
anderen mehr und das einzige was der
Staat antwortet ist Gewalt und deshalb
werden die Protest auch so schnell nicht
abben vier Hinrichtungen sind bereits
vollstreckt worden weitere Demonstranten
stehen auf der Todesliste und von der
Bundesregierung kommt wenig bis nichts
warum eigentlich
das sehe ich nicht so aller Sanktionen
die bisher von der Europäischen Union
verhängt worden sind sind auf Betreiben
unsere Außenministerin Annalena baerbock
zustande gekommen dass mehr sein muss
hat sie selbst sehr klar und deutlich
zum Ausdruck gebracht dass Sanktionen
und damit Druck europaweit abgestimmt
werden müssen ist Rechtslage und
politisch ratsam und deshalb arbeitet
sie weiterhin dran damit es eine neuen
Druck gibt neue Sanktionen gibt denn die
Barbarei dieses Regimes ist wirklich
nicht auszuhalten und brauchen
entschiedene Antwort auch der Europäer
tatsächlich hat ja die Außenministerin
ihre Parteifreundin gestern eine
Erhöhung des Drucks auf Iran gefordert
abgesehen davon dass sie hier handeln
könnte welche Sanktionen würden denn den
Druck auf das Regime jetzt wirklich
erhöhen
ja sie handelt sie trägt zahlreiche
Vorschläge
im Kreise ihrer Kollegin Kolleginnen da
Außenminister der Europäischen Union vor
die müssen nur alle am Ende zustimmen
das zentrale Instrument was auch sie
nach vorne versucht zu treiben wo es
sehr schwierig ist weil es nicht alle
wollen ist dass die kernsäule der
Repression im Iran die Organisation die
wirklich am meisten dafür verantwortlich
ist dass die Menschen unterdrückt werden
dass Leute hingerichtet werden dass
Leute gefoltert werden verschleppt
werden verschwinden nämlich die
revolutions auf die Terrorliste der EU
kommen so kann man auch sehr viel
entschiedener etwas gegen ihre
Finanzierungswege machen um dahin zu
kommen um das hinzubekommen braucht es
aber die einstimmigkeiten der EU und
daran wird gearbeitet auch und gerade
durch hier die Bundesregierung allen
voran durch die Außenministerin und es
braucht eine Rechtsgrundlage die
geschaffen werden muss auch daran wird
gearbeitet aber man muss auch sehen dass
der Radius der Europäer im erfahren
nicht endlos ist wir müssen Druck machen
aber es wird dauern bis diese Sanktion
noch greifen aber tatsächlich ist es ja
so dass sie und auch Annalena baerbock
und die FDP dass alle fordern woran hakt
es denn warum geht das auf EU-Ebene
nicht voran
weil es Staaten gibt die die
Revolutionsgardisten nicht auf die
Terror setzen lässt setzen wollen ich
weiß nicht warum vielleicht weil sie
glauben dass das beim atomabkommen und
bei den Verhandlungen dort nicht
vorankommen wurde wenn man das täte es
kommt sowieso nicht voran bei den
Atomverhandlungen der Zeit und ist auch
nicht absehbar dass sich das ändert
deshalb ist ein richtiger Schritt aber
dafür müssen andere europäische Staaten
sich bewegen das schärfste sanktionswert
sie haben es angesprochen wäre ja die
Aufkündigung des atomabkommens mit Iran
und dadurch dann die Wiedereinsetzung
von Sanktionen warum hält die
Bundesregierung trotzdem am atomabkommen
Fest
es wird ja gerade nicht verhandelt es
ist ja alles ausgesetzt es ist auch
überhaupt nicht sinnvoll zur Zeit zu
verhandeln mit sehr iranischen Seite
gleichzeitig sehen wir ja dass sie die
Zentrifugen mit großer Geschwindigkeit
laufen lassen dass sie massiv ihre
eigenen Vereinbarungen aus dem Abkommen
auch verletzen so dass es mittlerweile
zunehmend in einer Sackgasse Gerät diese
Verhandlungen sehen nicht aus also
würden Sie zu irgendeinem Erfolg noch
führen können und auch da gilt es
dennoch dass die Staaten die da das
Abkommen bisher verhandelt haben und auf
der westlichen Seite sind es nicht nur
Deutschland sondern auch Großbritannien
Frankreich und vor allem die USA dass
sie nicht auseinander dividiert werden
dürfen die müssen zusammen aufstehen und
den Raum verlassen das funktioniert
nicht
vielen Dank für das Gespräch um mit
nuripur war das ko-chef der Grünen
schönen Abend nach Berlin
danke
das Gespräch haben wir aus Termingründen
am Abend aufgezeichnet und hier macht
jetzt Heins weiter mit den Nachrichten
und die beginnen mit einem Anti
terror-einsatz nach diesem Einsatz mit
der Festnahme von zwei Verdächtigen
wegen mutmaßliche Anschlagspläne hat
bundesinnenministerin Fräser erklärt ist
sei weiterhin höchste Wachsamkeit
geboten um uns gegen islamistischen
Terror zu schützen in der vergangenen
Nacht waren im Ruhrgebiet ein 32 Jahre
alter Iraner und sein Bruder in
Gewahrsam genommen worden der Verdacht
es sollen Giftstoffe beschafft worden
sein mit denen ein Anschlag begangen
werden kann zumindest bei der
Durchsuchung der Wohnung des
Verdächtigen fanden die Einsatzkräfte
aber keine Giftstoffe
die SPD-Spitze ist in Berlin zu einer
jahresauftaktklausur zusammengekommen
dabei wurde unter anderem eine
Resolution für die Erneuerung und den
Ausbau der Infrastruktur in Deutschland
beschlossen mit besseren
Investitionsbedingungen staatlichen
Beteiligungen und schnelleren Planungs-
und Genehmigungsverfahren außerdem will
der Parteivorstand mit den besich der
Parteivorstand mit den vier anstehenden
Landtagswahlen befassen
das russische Militär hat heute wieder
verstärkt Gebiete im Osten und Süden der
Ukraine angegriffen nach ukrainischen
Angaben wurden zwei Menschen getötet und
acht verletzt der russische Angriff auf
die Ukraine hat nach Angaben des un
flüchtlingshilfswerks zur größten
Fluchtbewegung seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg geführt laut UNHCR sind mehr
als 7,9 Millionen Menschen aus der
Ukraine geflohen und weitere 5,9
Millionen innerhalb des Landes
vertrieben das entsprechende Bevölkerung
nach drei Jahren Abschottung und
nullcovic-politik hat China seine
Grenzen geöffnet inzwischen fahren auch
wieder Züge zwischen dem Festland und
Hongkong für Einreisende gibt es keine
quarantänepflicht mehr die Öffnung
erfolgt mit dem Auftakt der diesjährigen
Reisesaison zum chinesischen
Neujahrsfest viele Familien sehen sich
nach Monaten der Trennung zum ersten Mal
wieder
die Räumung von lützerath rückt näher
und beide Seiten bringen sich für den
Showdown nächste Woche in Stellung das
nordrhein-westfälische Innenministerium
hat ein Kräfte Ersuchen an alle anderen
Bundesländer gestellt sprich
Polizeihundertschaften aus ganz
Deutschland angefordert auch die
Aktivisten die das Dorf besetzt halten
sammeln sich und trainieren den
Widerstand lützerath ist ein Symbol für
beide Seiten
hier nordwestlich von Köln liegt das
rheinische braunkohle-revier mit den
tagebauern Garzweiler 1 und 2 die Größe
von Garzweiler 2 ist im Laufe der Zeit
auf etwa 48 Quadratkilometern
zusammengeschrumpft und es bleiben nach
den neuesten Plänen einige Ortschaften
am nördlichen Rand erhalten lützerath
gehört jedoch nicht dazu der kleine Ort
ist längst nur noch von klimaaktivisten
bewohnt die lützerather selbst sind alle
umgesiedelt die kohleflöte unter dem
Dorf sind besonders dick und liegen in
bis zu 210 Metern Tiefe der
Energiekonzern RWE gibt an dass er genau
diese Kohle brauche um das wegfallende
russische Gas zu ersetzen die
klimaaktivisten halten dagegen die
lützerather Kohle sei für die
Energieversorgung Deutschlands
unerheblich
lützerath unräumbar war die Überschrift
des heutigen Aktionstages im braunkohle-
die Kohle unter diesem Dorf wird mich
gebraucht die Band annenmaykantereit
spielt an der Abbruchkante an diesem
lützerath-protestag im Rheinischen
Revier es sind viele gekommen und gegen
die bevorstehende Räumung zu
protestieren
wir überschreiten konsequent das Pariser
Klimaabkommen und dafür ist eben so
unglaublich wichtig dass eben die Kohle
im Boden bleibt wir zeigen dass wir
viele sind und wir zeigen dass wir uns
von diesen Polizeieinsatz der am Montag
gestartet hat dass wir uns davon nicht
einschüchtern lassen
kohlestop rufen Sie und üben möglichst
wirksame Sitzblockaden sie wollen der
Polizei allen widerstanden
entgegensetzen die bereitet sich auf
einen massiven Einsatz vor auf einen
schwierigen Einsatz Baumhäuser
evakuieren Menschen nicht gefährden na
an der Abbruchkante aufgrund der
Wetterlage und eines wasserrohrschadens
der da in den Bereich gestern sich
ereignet hat gibt es immer wieder Teile
von abrokante die wirklich abrutschen
und wir möchten an der Stelle dringend
darauf hinweisen es besteht akute
Lebensgefahr an der Bruchkante RWE soll
die Kohle unter lützerath bekommen dafür
wird der Kohleausstieg auf 2030
vorgezogen ein Kompromiss von den Grünen
verhandelt sie regieren mit dem Bund und
Land
vor Ort in lützerath protestieren
Umweltgruppen die der Partei nahe stehen
Greenpeace Fridays for future auf die
grüne Parteijugend ist dabei die
lützerat Räumung eine grüne
Belastungsprobe wir brauchen
Energieversorgungssicherheit das ist für
alle die sich für Klimaschutz einsetzen
herausfordernde Situation jetzt temporär
mehr CO2 zu imitieren als eigentlich
geplant insofern ist das ein bewegender
Moment auch für eine grüne Partei die
Grüne Partei die einst ihren
Landesparteitag solidarisch an einer
Abbruchkante abhielt er regierte sie
allerdings noch nicht mit nun koalieren
die Grünen in Nordrhein-Westfalen mit
der CDU der Partei die früher auch den
Einsatz im Hambacher Forst verantwortete
der Innenminister ist auch jetzt auf
Gewalt vorbereitet ich rechne auch damit
dass wir einen harten Kern von Menschen
haben werden die sich an keine Regeln
halten die ihr eigenes Leben riskieren
die gewalttätig werden und denen auch
gar nicht im Klima geht sondern den es
um ja ich habe Überwindung des
kapitalistischen Unternehmen unseres
Staates geht nach dem Konzert heute
kommt es auch zu diesen Szenen später
beruhigt sich die Lage die meisten
dürften wohl friedlich Widerstand üben
auf den bereiten sie sich an diesem
Abend weiter vor ab übermorgen wäre die
Räumung rechtlich möglich
ich weiß nicht was sie gemacht haben im
Alter zwischen 13 bis und 16 aber
vermutlich haben sie nicht monatelang
mit ihren Eltern zu Hause gesessen so
erging es aber den Teenagern der jetzt
Zeit sie waren durch die corona-pandemie
plötzlich abgeschnitten vom Kontakt mit
Gleichaltrigen der gewohnte Alltag mit
Sport und Freunden brach weg und für
viele ist der Wiedereinstieg ins Leben
davor plötzlich unmöglich die Realität
kaum auszuhalten mit Nachrichten von
Krieg und Klimakrise die ständig auf sie
einstürzen gleichzeitig sind die
Wartezeiten für psychotherapeutische
Behandlungen fast doppelt so lang wie
vor der Pandemie
erzählt die Geschichte von Eva die durch
schwere Zeiten geht
bei mir fühlt sich so ein bisschen
einfach wie so eine Lehre an die einen
von innen raus so ein bisschen auffrisst
und die einem vorschreibt wie man zu
leben hat die einem irgendwie sagt was
man machen darf und was man nicht machen
darf
eva ist 13 als sie das erste Mal auf die
krisenstation der Psychiatrie in
Tübingen kommt eine Notaufnahme mitten
im ersten corona-lockdown verliert sie
den Halt ist schwer depressiv lebensmüde
also das erste mal was total schlimm für
mich so oh ich musste eine Psychiatrie
und konnte dann erstmal
reflektieren was zur Hölle ist gerade
passiert wir wo bin ich jetzt heute ist
Eva 15 und wieder hier diesmal nach
einem Suizid versucht wieder kam sie als
Notfall einer von mehr als 400 im
vergangenen Jahr berichtet Psychiater
Gottfried Bart die meisten Betroffenen
sein Mädchen
grundsätzlich haben wir immer den
Unterschied dass Mädchen eine höhere
Tendenz zu internalisierenden Störungen
wie zum Beispiel Depression haben oder
Essstörungen auch
und Jungs eher durch
sozialverhaltensstörungen Aggressivität
ihre Affekte bewältigen es seien die
vielen Krisen Pandemie Krieg in Europa
all das belaste junge Menschen massiv
die Folge Zukunftsängste vor allem in
der Pubertät sei es schwer Probleme zu
verarbeiten es sind zwei Faktoren die
dann noch dazukommen
sie haben Elternhaus sie haben zu Hause
das auch belastet ist das heißt da ist
weniger Stabilität da und das zweite die
Kinder und Jugendliche sind ja heute
alle hautnah informiert mit allem was in
der ganzen Welt passiert und das
auszuhalten ist eine riesige
Herausforderung und eine zunehmende
Anzahl oft richtig toller und begabter
Kinder Jugendlichen
brechen dort zusammen helfen könnte
vielen eine langfristige Therapie doch
es gibt zu wenig Plätze obwohl
Baden-Württemberg zuletzt aufgestockt
hatte allein in Tübingen stehen mehr als
50 Kinder und Jugendliche auf der
Warteliste eine von ihnen ist Eva
es ist halt schon sehr doof wenn man
einfach nicht weiß wann es weitergeht
bis sie einen Platz hat wird Eva auf der
Notfallstation bleiben hier fühlt sie
sich sicher und lernt Methoden mit der
Angst der Lehre der Überforderung
umzugehen alles was ablenkt hilft
zumindest für den Moment
und wir machen weiter mit Nachrichten
vom Sport und mit Heinz die deutsche
Handball-Nationalmannschaft hat heute
ihr letztes Testspiel vor der WM
bestritten und holte einen 33 zu 31 Sieg
gegen Island die WM in Polen und
Schweden beginnt am Mittwoch erste Spiel
der deutschen Mannschaft ist am Freitag
gegen Katar zu sehen hier im ZDF
im Slalom Weltcup hat es Linus Strasser
heute in Adelboden ein weiteres Mal aufs
Podest geschafft er wurde Dritter hinter
zwei Norwegen
linusstraße zum dritten Mal nacheinander
auf dem Podium von Adelboden beim
Weltcup Slalom in der Schweiz waren
lediglich die beiden Norweger Lukas
brotten und Adler schneller als der
30-Jährige der das Traditionsrennen in
Berner Oberland mehr als schätzt
zeichnen immer das beste Rennen im Ski
Weltcup also jeder der wirklichen coolen
Weltcup sehen will der muss in Album
gewesen sein für straßenverweis nach
Platz 3 in Madonna di Campiglio der 2
Podestplatz in dieser Saison in der
Slalom Weltcup Wertung verbessert sich
der Münchner auf Platz 6
Anton Tremmel feierte als 13 das beste
Weltcup Ergebnis seiner Karriere
[Applaus]
Francesco Friedrich hat trotz seiner
Muskelverletzung beim Weltcup in
Winterberg im Vierer Bob gewonnen sein
71 Weltcupsieg im Zweier Bob der Frauen
gingen die Plätze 1-3 an deutsche Teams
dass du Nolte shootengewand vor den
Teams buckwitz Lipperheide und kaliki
Fiebig kaliki führt nach vier von acht
Rennen auch in der zweier Bob Weltcup
Gesamtwertung
dafür dass der britische Prinz Harry
sein ganzes Leben lang unter mangelnder
Privatsphäre gelitten hat plaudert er
jetzt sehr eifrig und für sehr viel Geld
über dieses sein Privatleben Krach mit
dem ehemals geliebten Bruder der erste
Sex hinter dem Pub Erfahrungen mit
Kokain und psycho-pilzen noch bevor die
Biografie erschienen und die exklusiv
TV-Interviews gesendet sind ahnt die
Welt dass die Queen sich wohl im Grabe
umdrehen würde und der Rest des
Königshauses genervt Schweigen wird
Andreas stammen mit den Reaktionen auf
den royalen Seelen Striptease in
Großbritannien
ein wenig Werbung für Krieg der Sterne
das wenige Jahre später ein Krieg der
Prinzen ausbricht zwischen den
unzertrennlichen Brüdern Schienen
denkbar doch an Harrys Frau scheiden sie
sich William soll Meghan beleidigt haben
der Streit eskaliert so Harry bis zum
täglichen Angriff durch den Bruder
im aufsteigen er wollte dass
zurückschlage aber ich entschied mich
dagegen
Harrys Autobiografie sollte erst
kommende Woche veröffentlicht werden
doch einen spanischer Buchhändler
verkauft zu früh wohl ein Versehen der
britische Boulevard lässt übersetzen und
die Briten packt das Entsetzen Harris
sich der Dinge flankiert von großen
TV-Interviews er beschreibt seine
Entjungferung mit 17 oder Drogen
Missbrauch Hasch Pilze Kokain
früher der wilde Winzer genannt schon
sich nicht doch die schonungslose
Offenheit was seine Familie betrifft ist
Sprengstoff Vater Charles sei
gefühlskalt er und William hätten
Charles Hochzeit mit Camilla der bösen
Stiefmutter verhindern wollen Harry in
naziuniform sein Bruder der Thronfolger
habe ihn damals darin bestärkt
sind zutiefst persönliche und intime
Einblicke verstörend es fällt einem die
Kinnlade herunter bei Dingen mit denen
sich die royale Familie lieber im
Privaten auseinandergesetzt hätte das
schadet enorm keine neuen Details gibt
es zu den rassismusvorwürfen aber wer
weiß was später noch kommt
statt einer Familie die ihn beschützt
sei er Gefangener einer Institution
Derne halt werdet zur Not auch die
Menschlichkeit untergeordnet und so wird
ein zwölfjährige gezwungen hinter dem
Sarg seiner Mutter zu laufen
ich lächelte ich habe die Aufnahmen
gesehen wirklich jeder dachte und
trauerte als ob sie unsere Mutter
gekannt hätten und die beiden die am
nächsten standen konnten keine Emotionen
zeigen
doch was außer vielleicht Rache und mehr
als 100 Millionen Dollar für Interviews
Doku Serie und Buch treibt ihn zur
Abrechnung mit seiner Familie über die
Presse die der Prinz zu verabscheut Sam
dagegen gekämpft dass Ihre Privatsphäre
ständig verletzt wird sie werden ihnen
vorwerfen dass sie genau das den
Menschen antun die Ihnen am wichtigsten
und nächsten sind ohne deren Erlaubnis
das werden nur die sagen die nicht
verstehen oder glauben wollen dass meine
Familie Geschichten gegen mich an die
Presse lanciert hat
Beweise bleibt er dafür schuldig dafür
beweist Harry mangelndes diplomatisches
Feingefühl in dem er erklärt er habe
während seiner Armeezeit in Afghanistan
25 Taliban getötet
viele Militärs und sicherheitsexperten
haben diese Aussage kritisiert da ist
die Gefahr und Bedrohung für Harry seine
Familie aber auch für die königliche
Familie erhöht die Taliban haben sich ja
dazu schon verärgert
selbst Zerstörer der etwas Erstaunliches
schafft dass die Briten mehrheitlich
Mitgefühl mit den eher hölzernen Figuren
im Königshaus Charles und William
entwickeln und der einstige
Sympathieträger Harry im Krieg der als
Verlierer da steht
und nächste Woche geschehen auch noch
ein paar wichtige Dinge Annegret Oster
mit dem heute journal Ausblick
[Musik]
nach den gewalttätigen Angriffen auf
Einsatzkräfte in der Silvesternacht in
Berlin wird dort am Mittwoch ein Gipfel
gegen Jugendgewalt stattfinden es
brauche einen Mix aus ausgestreckte Hand
und Stoppsignal sagte die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin Franziska Giffey nach
den Krawallen ist eine Diskussion
darüber entbrannt was genau die Ursachen
und Hintergründe der massiven Attacken
sind
Außenministerin baerbock wird am
Donnerstag zusammen mit ihrer
französischen Amtskollegin Colonna in
Äthiopien eintreffen Ziel des Besuchs
die Festigung des Friedensabkommens für
die Region Tigray vor gut zwei Jahren
war ein Machtkampf zwischen der
äthiopischen Zentralregierung und der
bis dahin herrschenden
volksbefreiungsfront von T3 zu einem
blutigen Krieg eskaliert schätzungen
zufolge starben eine halbe Million
Menschen mindestens 2 Millionen Menschen
wurden vertrieben
am Sonntag wird in Alicante das
prestigeträchtige Ocean Race starten die
insgesamt 60.000 km lange Strecke rund
um die Welt führt um die Südspitze
Afrikas weiter nach Brasilien und die
USA und endet in Genua als erste
deutsche Seglerin nimmt Olympia zweite
Susan Beuke an der seit 50 Jahren
ausgetragenen regatta-teile
und noch die Wetteraussichten zum Start
in die neue Woche Morgen zieht der Regen
im Nordosten ab sonst gibt es viele
Schauer in hohenlagen als Schnee im
Westen sind Gewitter möglich bei dem
Südwestwind liegen die Höchstwerte
zwischen 4 und 10 Grad windig und
unbeständig geht es weiter teils auch
mit längeren Regen vorübergehend schneit
es bis auf 600 Meter herab insgesamt
bleibt es aber mild am Mittwoch werden
sogar sieben bis 13 Grad erreicht
das war es von uns morgen erwarten Sie
hier Christian Sievers und Hanna
Zimmermann und um 0.30 gibt es dann die
nächste heute Express einen schönen
Abend ihnen und Tschüss wiedersehen
[Musik]